when people on your thing give you
negative feedback do you pay attention
to that do you kind of change what
you're doing do you get affected by it I
think feedback and negative comments are
different if it's I read comments and I
learn and I love my audience I like
connecting with them so I want to know
what they're saying and I want to you
know take feedback from them if it is
something that what are the mean things
though what do they say I'm talking
about the shitty things the shitty
things it doesn't really bother me I
mean there's so much out there like I
don't know I've never been a person to
be reflected by that I get so if I've
been doing this thing a long time I will
yeah I will not I have a very thin skin
I'm good at dishing it out yeah
I cannot take it I don't want to hear
anything anyone has to say about me it
affects my performance because I get
influenced by it yeah but like would you
ever go on a post of a random person you
don't know and start commenting like
about their looks or about them never so
it's like these people are weirdos like
why do you even care
thank you